[Musique]
une filière qui ne se porte pas au mieux
de sa forme et qui va quand même
réfléchir à son avenir à l'occasion de
la quatrième édition du ty coz et et du
trophée cobaty martinique ce sera demain
vendredi
ce secteur est bien c'est celui du
bâtiment et travaux publics bonjour tony
buckley bonjour ou se veulent eux dont
vous êtes le vice-président du cobaty
martinique on va rôder finir pour ceux
qui nous suivent le cobaty c'est une
fédération internationale des
associations issues de tous pays qui
regroupe toutes celles et tous ceux dont
l'activité professionnelle et concernés
par l'acte de bâtir l'urbanisme ou
l'environnement
et ça c'est déjà une belle performance
que tout le monde se réunit ce week au
bâti c'est une très belle fédération de
4500 membres à peu près donc aller
cobaty partout en france
mais on a aussi en belgique en suisse et
puis dans certains pays du moyen orient
le liban le maroc et se sont développées
leurs expériences voilà il partage
d'expériences et l'objectif alors on
réunit tout le monde du notaire de
l'avocat ceux qui manient la ruelle
l'architecte les maîtres d'ouvragé puis
même les housses les huissiers 6 s'il ya
un souci alors le réflexe le cobaty
réfléchi à ce secteur du btp et première
chose pour 2009 vous mettra encore une
fois à l'honneur les jeunes qui sont en
formation parce que ça aussi c'est de
devenir du secteur
oui toujours 2019 alors toujours aussi
sauf ça fait partie de nos missions de
promouvoir la formation des jeunes
ça fait partie de l'adn de cobaty on va
dire et en fait ça se matérialise par un
trophée qu'on remet un jeu de méritants
et sas s'est organisée dans tous les cas
bâti dans tous les cas bâti le français
de annaba et le message à faire passer à
ces jeunes est bien c'est que en dépit
de tout ce qu'on dit concernant le btp
il y encore de l'avenir
et ce secteur qui est en pleine mutation
le message à faire passer à ces jeunes
c'est de leur dire de s'accrocher parce
que ça serait mentir de dire que c'est
facile
mais c'est aussi de leur dire qu'il ya
de très belles perspectives qu'il faut
simplement s'intéresser à ce qu'on fait
comprendre les mutations
ce qui n'est pas toujours évident et
puis essayer de dénicher un métier que
la personne à côté de vous ne sera pas
fermée que vous saurez faire
ouais mais quand ces jeunes martiniquais
puisqu'on va parler de notre île d'abord
un camp c'est jeune martiniquais en
temps de dire qu'il ya de moins en moins
de chantiers que les ventes de ciment
stagne voire régresse et que il n'y a
pas d'avenir pour ce secteur vous dit
quoi que ce soit moi je dis que ce que
j'ai l'habitude de dire je dis qu'on est
dans une période de mutation c'est vrai
les difficiles et douloureuses parce
qu'il ya des choses qui se faisait
abondamment avant qu'ils ne vont plus se
faire en même temps il ya d'autres
perspectives qui s'ouvrent bien d'autres
persos est si puissant et et je pense
qu'il faut qu'ils soient attentifs et
bien écoutez on l'a on parle d'économie
circulaire là en l'occurrence là bientôt
en matière d'économie circulaire il y a
des choses à faire
moi le pommeau exemple qui me vient en
tête c'est un truc tout bête c'est les
nettoyages de chantier est aujourd'hui
avant l'étape de chantier se faisait un
petit peu et puis ça ouais aujourd'hui
savent c'est un vrai métier et iliad il
ya des entrepreneurs qui arrivent à
tirer leur épingle du jeu en étant
organisés on ira qui a un savoir faire
et puis en essayant de respecter les
règles de l'environnement on peut
arriver à ont peut arriver à développer
a développé un business
lorsqu'on regarde l'état de de nos
structures en martinique je parle du
bâti les maisons les bâtiments publics
on voit bien qui de toute façon il va
falloir avait peut-être donné un beau
coup de pioche à tout cela est peut être
rebâtie reconstruire mais finalement ce
qu'il a manqué c'est l'argent tout
simplement
oui c'est vrai bon l'argent il faut
aller le chercher là où il est bon si on
prend la chose d'un point de vue
national vont le gouvernement a depuis
quelques temps travaillé sur un grenelle
de l'environnement il en est sorti un
certain nombre de décisions budgétaires
sur les rénovations qu'on a qualifié d'
énergétique
bon ce sont des dispositifs qui sont pas
encore très développée ici mais moi je
pense qu'il ya à creuser là vous avez
l'impression que l'on rame un peu plus
ici en martinique pas forcément c'est à
dire que c'est sûr qu'il ya toujours une
chance à jean de délai entre ce qui se
décide à 7000 km est ici bon tu normal
parce qu'il faut toujours adapter un an
nonce c'est bien qu'on ait un
département français mais se rend bien
compte qu'on fout ici en martinique on
ne fonctionne pas comme en france ne
serait ce que si on prend le cas du
climat on n'est pas du tout dans les
mêmes dans les mêmes prérogatives donc
toutes les décisions prises en mai
propose donc faire l'objet d'une
adaptation donc il ya toujours un jour
de décalage mais faut il faut développer
une ingénierie martiniquaise revenons à
ce concept de d'économie circulaire
c'est à dire que vous proposez par
exemple que qu'on travaille sur de
nouvelles filières de nouvelle
conception de nouveaux traitements pour
le bâti martiniquais oui bon enfin pour
moi c'est quelque chose qui tombe sous
le sens quoi il suffit il suffit
d'ouvrir les yeux aujourd'hui on jusqu'à
maintenant quand on a besoin d'une
ressource on allait acheter un ou alors
au nom ou alors on allait l'extraire
dans notre sol annonce on se rend bien
compte que la ressource n'est pas
inépuisable
donc l'idée c'est de se dire que
il faut trouver d'autres ressources
ouais et en l'occurrence en ce moment
bien compte que lors des opérations de
déconstruction en génère un certain
nombre de matériaux que jusqu'à non
qualifiés de déchets mais au fait ces
déchets peuvent très bien être
transformé en en ressources les exemples
sont multiples par exemple bien donnez
nous quelques exemples est ce que est ce
que nous nous avons suffisamment de
volume pouvoir créer de nouvelles
filières qui pourrait satisfaire toute
la martinique
ah ouais là vous là vous touchez pile
poil dans le don vous touchez du doigt
le côté compliqué de la faire et c'est
vrai que c'est le groupe problème mon
avis un de du développement de cette
économie c'est que les méthodes de
production les moyens de production ne
sont pas adaptés à la petitesse de notre
territoire dans l'exécution la
guadeloupe
ah ben c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça tout
l'enjeu vous dites la guadeloupe moi je
moi je serais prêt à aller plus loin il
faut associer toute la caraïbe
parce que quand vous quand vous regardez
bien la martinique et même la guadeloupe
c'est même un million de personnes
voilà donc pour moi l'avenir de
l'économie circulaire rien ici un avenir
caribéen mais tout reste à faire en ce
domaine parce que les contres et
administratifs sont multiples lorsque
vous voyez par exemple tout ce qu'on
fait avec les plastiques dorée de
récupération c'est quelque chose qu'on
pourrait imaginer ici par exemple
quelques passerelles quelques quelques
façades avec du plastique de
récupération je pose la question parce
que je pense à tout à coup c'est des
choses qu'on pourrait imaginer a
traversé cobaty le plastique
je sais pas si on trouve des
applications immédiates dans le btp a
joué durant l'application à d'autres
impôts la réputation du plastique
il ya un monsieur qui a mis en place une
usine de
de de retraitement des plastiques et il
a dû d'ailleurs du mal à s'en sortir
parce que l'astre fameux problème de
ressources il n'a pas assez d'entrants
pour faire tourner son une petite
production correctement maintenant on
peut prendre notre exemple le verre par
exemple qui jusqu'à maintenant a éprouvé
du en grande quantité et kiiki et de
différentes origines à une fois qu'on
l'a mis en miettes
ben on peut s'en servir comme matériau
de remblai et ça ça fonctionne très bien
bon il ya d'autres exemples
j'ai parlé des constructions tout à
l'heure quand on dit construire un
bâtiment on récupère l'acier enfin en
plus grosses cotes les plus grosses
quantités de matériaux qu'on récupère
ses l'acier et le béton le bouton casser
ton concassées et pareil ces matériaux
peuvent être réutilisés pour des
applications diverses et variées l'acier
par an contre ça fait l'objet d'une
cyclage ici il n'y a pas d'unité de
production de retraitement d'acier par
contre l'idée c'est de les collecter et
de l'envoyer vers les centres de
traitement et opère en europe aura
l'occasion donc de ce qui cause et qui
se tiendra demain demain matin à
l'institut martiniquais du sport merci
tony hawk ride avoir été avec nous
rappelle tous vous êtes le
vice-président du cobaty martinique
merci d'avoir été avec nous dans son
crédit bonne journée merci à vous